okay we've been talking off and on about
being about a hundred days into the
Donald Trump administration we've talked
about the historically low approval
ratings that we've seen from Donald
Trump
and it's been scandal after scandal
right the Russian collusion scandal
multiple law enforcement investigations
two failed Muslim majority immigration
bans we've had two failed sanctuary city
order we've had two failed repeal and
replacement of Obamacare it's a long
list I'll stop there and in an interview
with Fox News Donald Trump is blaming
the checks and balances that are
constitutionally supported that our
government has in place for his failures
what checks and balances have taught
stopped Trump from getting done what he
wanted to get done well maybe there's
something to it let's take a listen to
what Donnie boy had to say over the
years you know your views just changed
somewhat but I think more than anything
else I'm a person with common sense I
understand what has to be done I get
things done I've ever been at closer
we've had a lot of closers in politics
and I understand why so very rough
system it's a sin archaic system we look
at the rules of the Senate even the
rules of the house but the rules of the
Senate and some of the things you have
to go through it's it's really a bad
thing for the country in my opinion
their archaic rules and maybe at some
point we're going have to take those
rules on because for the good of the
nation things are going to have to be
different you can't go through a process
like this it's not fair it forces you to
make bad decisions I mean really forced
into doing things it's just not fair Pat
all those pesky laws rules and
regulations are getting in Donald
Trump's way the things a president has
to go through to get his way whenever he
wants are bad for the country and the
rules should be changed
is it possible though that he's not
talking so much about the Constitution
and the systems of checks and balances
as he is just kind of these quirky
Senate traditions so for example when
Mitch McConnell got Elizabeth Warren to
sit down by invoking rule 13 or the fact
that the Republicans had to use a budget
reconciliation bill to try to push their
Health Care Act because that was they
were able to avoid a filibuster that way
yeah I get what you're saying I
understand what you're saying but if you
actually do a fair analysis of it
Trump has probably benefited from some
of those rules in the sense that you
know Neil Gorsuch should not even have
been confirmed the Republicans in the
Senate went in and changed the rules in
order to get Trump his way this is sort
of the main part of the presidential
oath of office wishes you're preserving
protecting and defending the
Constitution which includes checks and
balances which includes the rules of the
Senate the rules of the house and now
these are an impediment to Trump doing
whatever on earth you want so is he
directly attacking the Constitution no I
think you're right about that he's not
saying abolish the Constitution but it's
more the idea that this is how Trump
runs his businesses right or ran his
businesses well maybe he's still running
them I guess we're not really sure which
is up he gets his way what he says goes
he told us that's the way he would run
the country the only thing more absurd
than Trump saying this is his bamboozled
supporters the constitutional fetishists
who don't even seem to care that he's
saying checks and balances are getting
in the way and we should reduce them
this is almost impossible to parity it's
a real problem for comedy writers and
satirical shows because you can't really
do a satirical version of this and if
you want to focus on archaic parts of
how our government functions let's
change the archaic electoral college as
well as gerrymandering both of which
helped Trump and Republicans come to
power in a sense he's right you've got
to give him credit if it weren't for the
checks and balances of our system his
Muslim travel went travel bans would
probably be in place his sanctuary city
order would be in place as a board of
American Health Care Act would be in
place it would all have gone through so
in a sense he's right and we have that
to thank and although he'll claim that
he has great respect for the
Constitution this is a guy that maybe
has never even read the document maybe
it's six pages long and unregular sheets
of paper it's a quick read and Trump
also mentioned that the Constitution has
12 articles or so yeah it actually only
has seven well I don't think anyone
anyone is shocked right listen he is not
a details guy he's a big picture guy oh
wait a second over the weekend he said
in that
Reuters interview he is a details guy
well I don't know I can't explain why he
doesn't seem to know any of the details
on this but I guess he's just not happy
with the fact that he can't do whatever
it is that he wants to do